it's just getting ever it's like venom
coming out of that's like atrocious
that is a true the consistency
[Music]
check speak like i speak
speak like i speak should i put this on
my shirt on my sweatshirt
oh we could say both of our names i kind
of saw you
starting all right by the way this is
the start great i'm already living hey
i'm mike cannon i'm brendan sagalow and
we're gonna answer the internet and he's
gonna read publicly
okay
would you rather everyone be naked all
the time or clothes all the time there
was a time when i probably would have
found having sex through the zipper of
my jeans pretty exciting but then like
okay fine but like right now you're just
next to cycle and doing ati naked
yeah but that's fine
yeah no i do want you to know that it is
a pink peanut it's weirdly shaped it
looks like a kidney pool i'm telling you
there is a freedom in everyone knowing
what you look like naked but having pop
not having pockets would be a real issue
we'd have to kind of figure it out if
you just duct tape your wallet to the
side of your thighs and you're like this
is just how i roll dude i have cargo
legs does it bother you if a girl you're
dating makes more money than you
no if it did you'd be miserable
i'm currently dating someone that
doesn't make as much money than i do and
it is a kind of a miserable experience
kidding i'm kidding
would you rather have balls permanently
stuck to your leg or permanent swamp ass
i have
swamp ass the majority of time dude
there is an aquarium in my box of briefs
even in the winter and it feels it feels
like like an algae fish is cleaning me
sometimes it's [ __ ] up yeah and my
balls are a mess
so i i literally have a tough time if
someone offered to get rid of them
without any pain i'd probably take that
off well the problem with brendan's
balls and just speaking on his anatomy
because i have a deep knowledge of it
he has eczema so they crystallize and
harden and if that was locked to the
side of your leg that would be almost
like you were slamming your dick against
a glacial wall yeah it would be a
nightmare it'd be like those pods from
the matrix
up against my leg yeah yeah it'd be a
nightmare i put on cream the other night
on my balls because they were so dry and
they've been so like chapped and and and
open that it [ __ ] hurt
his balls look like the cast of alive
that's just how it is man what are you
gonna do did we answer
did you read the last one or did i i
have it are we do we start
would you give up a one inch of your
dick for six inches of height or vice
versa here's the thing forget him if i
was six seven my life might be different
like
i mean i am not honestly for real if i
was a six seven stretch small forward in
the in the early aughts and i learned
how to play like a guard but somebody
gave me a [ __ ] 5-inch dick who gives
a [ __ ] i would do that in a heartbeat to
be the first lamar odom
yeah i'm taking height because if you
add an extra inch to my dick i'm just a
regular guy
yeah now it's fun yeah now i'm just you
guys
now i'm a halloween snickers would you
rather every time you meet someone you
have to tell them you got your degree
online from the university of phoenix
and then say i am a phoenix
or
change your name to oliver and not be
able to use a nickname
that's just mean to two different people
someone from someone named oliver who
went to the phoenix yeah when i coached
soccer
it was like in downtown brooklyn years
ago for like all kids that had names
like ulysses and granola and
oliver and i remember this one piece of
[ __ ] oliver who was four or five years
old constantly mouthy and every once in
a while when we'd do running i would i
would successfully kick the ball in
between his legs and lock him up and
make him fall square on his
four-year-old face
and i was like wow oliver you almost had
it dude
so phoenix i guess
would you rather never get oral sex ever
again b
get only oral sex for the rest of your
life
hey
never get dude i could go without a
[ __ ] every day of the week yeah
vagina beats mouth in terms of comfort
100 of the time
i'm just getting a [ __ ] for you
i'm letting you you work out your
anxiety
yeah artists go crazy i've been watching
a lot of rim jobs lately
like i really like the idea of somebody
just like hoisting it up and going down
underneath it's like
i don't know i mean if that's involved
then maybe but would you rather only be
able to jerk off to naked girls you know
or fully clothed porn stars
naked girls oh my god yeah if i could do
that i would do that with like my ants
it was like just in your extended family
i'd be like that yeah
i have something against them i can
picture something is jerking off to
nudes of a girl who has died weird or a
nice tribute
i couldn't do that oh dude i've done it
i i i'm gonna say this might hit home
yeah dude i mean everybody in my life
has died so like
several women i've had sex with have
dropped dead almost immediately after
but
i have i have masturbated to their
memory to their yearbook picture to the
things i remember they said yeah i mean
here's the thing while i'm doing it
their nose doesn't like fall off and
they turn into a zombie like they've
been buried for a while it's still the
warm well then i'd be able to do it okay
would you rather a
leave a date with a hot chick for 10
minutes to take a [ __ ]
or b
hold it in and hope for the best i'll
tell you what and i was gonna when we
were doing your show i almost said this
story because but then we got right past
and if i said it again it would be
[ __ ] weird but
one time there was a girl over at my
house and i was holding in my farts for
so long that it made me have to like you
know that [ __ ] that comes out like like
if you were pushing applesauce slowly
out of your mouth
where it's like not a clean [ __ ] it's
just it's just
it's just getting ever it's like venom
coming out of that's like atrocious
that is a true the
consistency also
apple sauce spilling out of a mouth
immediately made me picture like a 90
year old
just coming out of the corner of their
face yeah and that's what it was
and i went i like had to go [ __ ] because
i was like holding in all these farts
and i sat and that came out and then i
had to take a shower because
it was just
it
wasn't good so i like came back to this
girl that's the peanut shaped [ __ ]
it came out in the infinity sign yeah
and i only i only washed the bottom of
my like i only spread my cheeks and
washed the [ __ ] out of my ass and then
washed my fingers and everything
okay and then i came back to her so only
my legs were wet
you're like ace ventura returning to the
party
don't go in there
if there was stats available for every
aspect of your life what one stat would
you want to see how am i doing
in terms of sheer numbers i would like i
have a ballpark in terms of how many
people i've slept with i have i don't
have an exact number but i have i do not
have even
an idea of how many times i've jerked
off or how much weed i've smoked that
would be that would be cool yeah but
then it would also be like you've spent
275 thousand dollars on marijuana and
it's like all right i'm gonna how much
does a gun cost here's a sad one how
many people have loved you
and they're like here's a sad one would
you rather lose a leg or never be able
to have sex again i'm fine with losing a
leg at this point in my life i feel like
that would help me comedically i have to
have a story at this point just pure
white doesn't help anybody so give me a
[ __ ] bum leg that i can go and just
toss into the front row uh what
percentage of internet porn do you think
you have seen well what do we
constitute as the entire the entire what
do you mean what are we constantly
sometimes i'm jerking off the things
that aren't necessarily poor all right
this question is over
what i'll do this thing
where i pull up cat videos
girls on tick tock of age
and but they're like kind of porn stars
but they're like really low level like
they have like 300 followers on twitter
but they're like posting their nudes and
like fingering themselves and stuff and
i i that i get in there
[Laughter]
so so you like just starting out slaves
that's cool that's cool man brenda likes
to get him but he wants to buy their nft
early yeah it's got to be 10
at most but i do feel like there's been
more but i'm i'm also very specific like
i don't i don't really adventure out
into like the dark arts or whatever like
i don't really go out into the deep end
i'm pure stepmother stuff like yeah
sister oh yeah we're so we're so like
numb by it that i'll be watching porn
i'll start laughing at it
this is a real insight into you
would you date your dream girl if for
two days every week your choice of days
she had to dress like a juggalo yes i've
always wanted to have sex with zakamiko
that's a deep cut yeah
yeah of course because a juggalo could
be hot as long as she's not you know
a juggalo but if she's like dressing
like that yeah she looked like harley
quinn accepted real cutter yeah
that is my dream girl
[Laughter]
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon